[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
[Applaus]
england ist
europameisterin im wembley-stadion haben
die deutschen fußballerinnen ein
dramatisches finale gegen england
verloren
ja schade und glückwunsch zum
erfolgreichen turnier der deutschen elf
und damit einen schönen sonntagabend
ihnen allen ein richtig richtig schöner
ist es natürlich für die englische
nationalelf und ihre fans die frauen
haben nach fünf und nach 56 jahren
wieder einen internationalen titel ins
land geholt und das genau in dem stadion
in dem england 1966 weltmeister wurde im
legendären und ausverkauften
wembley-stadion das turnier mit enormen
zuschauerzuspruch vermutlich auch balsam
für die sorgen geschundenen seelen von
millionen fußballfans die bilder und
reaktionen dieses nervenaufreibenden
fußballabends von marcel bergmann
der abschluss passt zu einer em in der
die gastgeberinnen auch das siegreiche
team stellen wie schon 1966 ging es in
die verlängerung in der das deutsche
team in wembley wieder nur zweiter
sieger wurde
[Musik]
ja wir haben es heute leider nicht
geschafft und deswegen sind wir jetzt ja
sehr enttäuscht bevor wir können uns auf
keinen fall machen also klar ist die
enttäuschung jetzt groß sind alle
traurig aber
wir können sicherlich sagen dass wir
haben ein sehr gutes turnier gespielt
haben zum sechsten mal tritt england mit
der selben startelf an während
deutschland nicht nur auf die in dieser
woche corona positiv getestete klara
buhl sondern auch auf die kurzfristig
verletzte top torschützin alexandra popp
verzichten muss von beginn an
entwickelte sich ein spannendes match in
dem marina hegering nach 29 minuten im
fünfmeterraum an den ball kommt der aber
von torhüterin obst aufgenommen werden
kann das handspiel von williamson wer
allerdings durchaus elfmeterwürdig
gewesen
in der 38 minute dann die beste chance
für die gastgeberinnen aus rund 14
metern bugs ellen white im strafraum
eine direktabnahme die zentrale knapp
über die querlatte segelt noch keine
tore zur halbzeit dann aber schickt wort
mit einem traumpass tun aus der eigenen
hälfte steigen und die gerade erst
eingewechselte trifft wunderbar per
heber über größeren strombeck ins linke
toreck die englische führung nach gut
einer stunde
nur vier minuten später die chance zum
ausgleich lina magull zieht mit rechts
wuchtig ab der schuss prallt vom gehäuse
zurück
in der 79 minute bedient lohmann
halbrechts im strafraum wasmuth die zur
einlaufenden magull passt und die mit
abstand beste deutsche lag in bar mit
drinks unter die querlatte zum längst
verdienten ausgleich
es geht in die verlängerung und in die
100 elfte minute eine englische ecke
prallt von grace kelly die den ball im
zweiten versuch über die linie spitzelte
beim letzten und entscheidenden treffer
dieser em hat das trikot am körper der
siegtorschütze in torrey kelly nicht zu
suchen
für beide teams endet eine unglaublich
stimmungsvoller europameisterschaft die
dem frauenfußball mit sicherheit viele
neue anhänger beschert hat
was für ein abend soll ja auch noch mal
dafür dass wir am anfang kathrin
hendrich und merle forums verwechselt
haben in den namen wir gehen ja darüber
nach london dort ist katja stresow für
uns katja wie hast du triumph und
niederlage im legendären wembley erlebt
ja es war unglaublich es war ein finale
das viele genauso erwartet haben ein
finale auf augenhöhe und wir haben es
gerade gehört die deutsche mannschaft
musste ganz kurzfristig den ausfall von
top torjägerin alex popp verkraften
deren aura deren ausstrahlung hier zum
teil dann doch auf dem platz gefehlt hat
aber trotzdem ein riesenkompliment an
die mannschaft von martina voss
tecklenburg die wirklich bis zur letzten
sekunde gekämpft hat und ja immer auf
augenhöhe war mit den engländerinnen und
deswegen würde ich am ende sagen es hat
vielleicht nicht die bessere mannschaft
gewonnen sondern die glücklichere aber
das gehört ja zum sport dann auch mit
dazu katja vielleicht eine turnierbilanz
ob man will oder nicht immer müssen sich
die frauen mit den männern vergleichen
lassen was denkst du wie viel aufwertung
für den frauenfußball hat diese em
gebracht
ich glaube extrem viel also man sieht es
an der zuschauerakzeptanz zu hause in
deutschland die einschaltquoten waren
noch nie so hoch wie aktuell im
frauenfußball das muss man wirklich so
festhalten und die mannschaft hat
gekämpft sie hat begeistert sie hat in
einer art und weise das turnier
gestaltet wie man es nicht erwartet hat
ganz einfach aus dem grund dass sie als
einheit funktioniert hat und diesen hype
den sie ausgelöst haben wie es die
spielerin selber immer wieder gesagt
haben den müssen sie jetzt schaffen
rüber zu retten und die bundestrainer
martina voss tecklenburg hat zu uns auch
im interview immer wieder betont wir
müssen uns im frauenfußball schaffen
dass das ganze hier nach halt dass
dieses turnier mit der akzeptanz auch
wirklich nachhaltigkeit erfährt und im
deutschen fussball hieße das dass die
professionalisierung jetzt auch im
frauenfußball einhält so wie es ja bei
den männern der fall ist das heißt dass
die trainingsbedingungen die wettkampf
die spielbedingungen genauso gut sind
wieder nimmt bei den männern und das
muss das ziel sein das ist ein harter
weg ein steiniger weg aber das muss das
hier sein was in deutschland auch
geschafft werden muss so wie es in
england und frankreich zum beispiel
schon längst der fall ist katja striesow
vielen dank und grüße nach london ja
jetzt der unvermeidlich hatte break vom
rauschhaften fußballfest zum
kriegsgeschehen in die ukraine mit
weiterhin massiven angriffen auf den
osten und süden des landes was die so
verzweifelte und wartete ausfuhr von
getreide aus den schwarzmeerhafen angeht
da haben die türkischen behörden heute
hoffnung gemacht das ist morgen so weit
sein könnte russland und ukraine
regierungschef sali hatten jeweils
ziemlich intensive auftritte präsident
see lenski rief die bewohner der region
bonn jetzt eindringlich dazu auf das
gebiet zu verlassen und wladimir putin
verschärfte seine drohungen richtung
westen in sankt petersburg mehr von
kameras auf java
ich gratuliere ihnen zum tag der
seestreitkräfte
das ist eine machtdemonstration putins
heute in sankt petersburg landesweit
wird der tag der marine gefeiert der
kreml führer nutzt das für eine
kampfansage an den westen mit einer
neuen marine doktrin sie sieht die usa
und die nato als die größten bedrohungen
russlands
wir werden den schutz unserer seegrenzen
fest und mit allen mitteln sicherstellen
die fähigkeiten der russischen marine
sind dabei das wichtigste sie ist in der
lage blitzartig auf jeden zu reagieren
denn unsere souveränität und freiheit
eingreifen will mit keinem wort erwähnt
putin heute den ukraine krieg vielmehr
droht er mit einer neuen waffe
es genügt wenn ich an dieser stelle das
neue hyperschall waffensystem zekorn
einfach nur anspreche es ist weltweit
einzigartig und kennt kein hindernis
die feier am sitz der russischen
schwarzmeerflotte in sewastopol dagegen
fällt aus ein ukrainischer
drohnenangriff mit mehreren verletzten
sei schuld sagt russland die ukraine
dementiert und spricht von einer
provokation
kämpfer und beschuss heute wieder in
vielen regionen der ukraine wie hier in
der zweitgrößten stadt fraglich
angesichts der russischen angriffe auf
der ukrainische präsident die einwohner
der region donetsk auf die region zu
verlassen
[Applaus]
das sind hunderttausende menschen
darunter tausende kinder viele wollen
nicht gehen bitte tun sie das jetzt denn
je mehr menschen das tun jetzt gebiet
verlassen erst so weniger menschen kann
die russische armee töten
tag 158 ukraine krieg russische
muskelspiele und keinerlei aussicht auf
frieden
was passiert wenn sich eine partei von
ihrem markenkern löst das ließ sich gut
bei der spd beobachten nach agenda 2010
und massiven sozialgesetz änderungen
wurde die krise quasi chronisch bis
eigentlich zur vergangenen
bundestagswahl
und was passiert jetzt mit den grünen
noch bis vor sechs monaten standen sie
für einen nein zu waffenlieferungen und
dass man kohlekraftwerke wieder an den
start bringt oder fragwürdige deals mit
partnern sucht bei denen menschenrechte
wenig zählen ist in der grünen
programmatik auch nicht vorgesehen hinzu
kommen mehrdeutige positionierungen zu
längeren akw-laufzeiten
zur zeitenwende der grünen und den
energie- streit in der ampel erklärte
sich heute die grünen chefin im zdf
sommerinterview
thomas reichert
es gibt gespräche da sitzt noch jemand
mit dem tisch quasi unsichtbar bei
diesem sommer interview mit der grünen
parteichefin ist dass christian lindner
der forderte in einem zeitungsinterview
atomkraftwerke müssten notfalls bis 2024
weiterlaufen der konflikt in der ampel
hat die offene bühne erreicht
dann geben sie eigentlich die gegenwehr
für eine verlängerung auf das heißt dass
kerner will ist nichts anderes als der
wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft und das
wird es mit uns auf jeden fall nicht
geben wer entlang in düsseldorf spricht
drängt linden in berlin vor die kameras
um noch einmal nachzulegen gegenwärtig
haben wir sichere laufende
kernkraftwerke wir müssen gas sparen das
dürfen wir nicht einsetzen für die
produktion von strom also ist es
sinnvoll und technisch möglich diese
anlage noch eine zeit länger zu
verwenden lang wiederum wirft lindner
eine unernste debatte vor atomkraft
helfe kaum fehlendes russisches gas zu
ersetzen und es ist so dass die
gaskraftwerke in deutschland nur zu
einem sehr kleinen teil der verstromung
angesetzt werden und da nur zu einem
winzigen teil durch die atomkraft
ersetzt werden könnte wer mein wärme
problemen kann stromproblem lang fordert
wegen hoher energiekosten
geringverdiener weiter zu entlasten
finanziert zum beispiel durch eine über
gewinn steuer für energiekonzerne die
aktuell viel höhere profite einfahren
wieder widerspruch von lindner
wir sollten alles unterlassen was
arbeitsplätze die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung das vertrauen in den
standort deutschland gefährdet wir
müssen alles tun um die menschen zu
schützen vor der inflation und ihre
ursachen zu bekämpfen und in diesem ziel
sind wir uns einig bei den wegen gibt es
vielleicht auch unterschiedliche reflexe
der streit geht an den kern der
koalition die grünen haben zwar
beliebtheits punkte gesammelt mussten
aber programm punkte liegen lassen bei
der fdp ist es genau umgekehrt
die grünen bekommen nun druck von der
basis und altgedienten christian
ströbele etwa fragt wegen
waffenlieferungen und einer möglichen
akw verlängerung nach grünen grundsätzen
wann kippt die nächste säule bloß nicht
auch deshalb fordert lang im zdf
entgegenkommen von fdp und spd wenn wir
als grüner mit klimaschutz in die
regierung gegangen sind jetzt
kohlekraftwerke länger laufen lassen ist
das schwierig wenn man als fdp ein
finanzsystem übernimmt und dann die
realität die schuldenbremse immer mehr
in frage stellt dann ist das schwierig
aber ich glaube da müssen dann alle
bereits einmal über ihren schatten zu
springen das erwarte ich auch vom
koalitionspartner
den zwist werden sie spätestens am ende
des sommers zu klären haben wenn sie in
der regierung dann tatsächlich alle
wieder an einem tisch sitzen
dieses jahr das ist ein hartes jahr für
alle die urlaub machen beziehungsweise
machen wollen zumindest mit dem flieger
die lufthansa und ihre kunden die müssen
sich womöglich auf weitere streiks
einstellen und er aber die gute
nachricht ist dass streik votum der
pilotengewerkschaft cockpit wo es nicht
zwangsläufig zu einem streik führen ein
entsprechender antrag wurde bislang
nicht gestellt zwar haben sich die
lufthansa piloten mit großer mehrheit
für einen arbeitskampf ausgesprochen
ziel ist aber zunächst eine stärkere
verhandlungsposition in den
festgefahrenen tarifkonflikt die piloten
fordern 5,5 prozent mehr gehalt einen
automatischen
inflationsausgleich sowie anpassungen in
den tarif strukturen in iran ist die
zahl der todesopfer nach den schweren
unwettern auf mindestens 69 gestiegen
zahlreiche menschen werden noch vermisst
extreme niederschläge hatten
überschwemmungen in 24 der 31 provinzen
verursacht nach behördenangaben sind
37.000 menschen obdachlos geworden in
den nächsten tagen wird mit weiteren
unsere blättern gerechnet
an der ehemaligen buchenwald bei weimar
sind weitere gedenksteine für ermordete
jüdische jugendliche verlegt worden
1944 waren sie von den
nationalsozialisten mit zügen über diese
strecke vom kz buchenwald in das
vernichtungslager auschwitz deportiert
worden mit den jetzt verlegten 111
gedenksteinen wird der opfer gedacht ein
projekt lebendige erinnerungskultur
die vorsitzende des us
repräsentantenhauses pelosi bricht heute
zu ihrer asienreise auf zuvor hatte sie
angekündigt mit einer delegation
singapur malaysia südkorea und japan zu
besuchen taiwan erwähnte sie nicht
spekulationen über einen besuch pelosis
in taiwan belasten das verhältnis der
usa zu china zusätzlich peking lehnt
besuche ausländischer politiker im
freiheitlichen taiwan grundsätzlich ab
sieht darin eine bestätigung der de
facto unabhängigkeit china droht immer
wieder mit einer eroberung taiwans
es war also bestimmt kein zufall dass
china ausgerechnet gestern in der nähe
taiwans ein manöver mit scharfer
munition abhielt der umgang für
westliche demokratien mit dem reich der
mitte der wird jedenfalls immer
schwieriger die frage für deutschland
und andere länder lautet nämlich schon
lange aber seitdem ukraine krieg erst
recht wo zieht man die grenze zwischen
vorteilhaften geschäften und gefährliche
abhängigkeit zu einem autokratisch
regierten land china hat in den
vergangenen 20 jahren einen
atemberaubenden aufstieg hingelegt das
durchschnittliche jahresgehalt von
beschäftigten verzehnfachte sich in
dieser zeit
seit präsident ski 2013 an die macht kam
ist die außenpolitik aggressiver die
innenpolitik autoritärer geworden mehr
über das machtstreben und den mann der
vielleicht bis in die 2030er regieren
könnte von ulf röller
er malt die die chinas schicksal
bestimmten und bestimmen bilder für die
geschichtsbücher john jenkins pinsel
sucht die größe in den personen maurer
steuermann überragte alle die ihm
folgten nun wandelt ein anderer auf
seinen spuren
schiebel auch ein ewiger präsident
werden john jenkins kunst darf daher nur
verehrung und keinen zweifel kennen
ich will presidential als einen menschen
malen der dem volk nahe steht
seine kunden sind loyale
parteimitglieder und reiche unternehmer
viele wollen einen ski zu hause hängen
haben verehrung schützt
denn sie trägt nicht nur den mao anzug
bei der 100 jahr feier der partei er
will wie mao die absolute macht
mit einem volk das dient
was wird präsident ließ vermächtnis sein
wo ich bin nicht in der position darüber
zu urteilen
er lässt sich onkel schienen inszeniert
sich als volkstribun gerade auch bei
seinem besuch in china
die uiguren die unterdrückte muslimische
minderheit müssen tanzen sie bestimmt
wird zur china dazu gehört wer einen
anderen gott neben ihm hat der landet im
lager es handelt sich um einen
rechtspopulistischen nationalismus dies
entspricht dem trend den wir in den
letzten zehn jahren in der welt
beobachten konnten zb bei putin und
erdogan
sieht sich als anführer der
kommunistischen welt beim bündnis mit
putin geht es um die neue weltordnung
sie will die demokratische insel taiwan
mit dem festland china vereinen notfalls
mit militärischer gewalt ein duell der
weltmächte amerika china droht die
chinesische führung ist entschlossen zu
zeigen dass china besser aufgestellt ist
als liberale demokratien dass man
effizienter innovation eure technologien
hervorbringen kann dass man
gesellschaften besser prägen kann um
auch mit mit krisen umzugehen
hat die volksrepublik gegründet wie wird
sie jetzt zu nie dagewesene größe führen
ein chinesisches jahrhundert das ist die
historische mission
und wir gehen jetzt nach peking zu ulf
röller ulf die spannungen zwischen china
und den usa die nehmen zu aktuell wegen
teil an womit ist zu rechnen
eigentlich ist damit zu rechnen dass
leider diese spannung weitergehen werden
unabhängig von einzelnen besuchen von
politikern denn wir haben ja eine
grundsätzliche rivalität und diese neue
weltordnung das verhältnis zwischen
amerika und china das hat sich halt noch
nicht eingependelt wir erinnern uns die
amerikaner hatten auch ihre politischen
hinterhöfe in lateinamerika oder im
nahen osten mit dem irak und haben dort
aus durchaus brutal ihre interessen
durchgesetzt dass halten jetzt die
chinesen uns vor und sagen das
südchinesische meer teil war das ist
unser einflussbereich und den wollen wir
mehr der weniger kontrollieren ob das
gerecht heißt dass es krieg gibt da bin
ich mir nicht wirklich sicher weil das
chinesische modell ist ein modell das
davon lebt dass es erfolg ökonomische
erfolg für seine bevölkerung organisiert
und wenn das nicht funktioniert ist das
modell in gefahr insofern um die
spannungen zu das heißt aber nicht
gleich dass es eine militärische
auseinandersetzung gibt wulff deine zeit
als korrespondent in china endet du
wirst bald aus brüssel für uns berichten
wir wollen dass sie zum anlass nehmen um
nach einem resümee zu fragen was nimmst
du mit aus china und worauf müssen uns
alle noch einstellen
also es waren ja zwei großereignisse die
die zeit geprägt haben das eine ist der
freiheitskampf in hongkong gewesen diese
zwei millionen menschen die für ihre
rechte und für die freiheit in der stadt
auf die straße gegangen sind das hat
mich sehr berührt und beeindruckt und
gleichzeitig muss ich sehen wie
effizient und geschickt die chinesische
diktatur diese freiheitsbewegung den
sauerstoff geraubt hat es gab eben kein
blut potsdam hat langsam die leute
festgenommen
und nun ist hongkong ein friedhof was
freiheitsrechte angeht und das andere
große thema war corona dazu beginnt die
chinesische regierung durchaus mit
brutalen maßnahme mit diesen lockt downs
das land wahrscheinlich davor gerettet
in dem abgrund einem chaos zu versinken
aber nun hat man die zwei jahre nicht
genutzt wirklich das land durch zu
impfen oder auch westlichen impfstoff
der noch ein bisschen besser ist hier
reinbringen zu lassen fiel aus stolz hat
man das nicht getan und nun muss man
diese brutale 0 kowitz strategie
durchsetzen und das gefährdet die
ökonomische lage die grundlage dieses
landes vielleicht noch eine persönliche
anmerkung leben in der diktatur ist
nicht immer einfach das viel kontrolle
manchmal auch angst aber es ist doch
ganz wichtig jedenfalls für mich gewesen
dass ich gelernt habe zu unterscheiden
zwischen dem staatsapparat und den
menschen die hier wunderbar waren und
der chinese ist eigentlich nicht viel
anders als wir er will ein bisschen
glück er will ein bisschen wohlstand und
er will dass es seinen kindern gut geht
und mit diesem wissen gehe ich mit
dankbarkeit jetzt weiter vielen dank für
die eindrücke und -analyse ulf röller
wir freuen uns auf dich in europa
dankeschön jetzt sind um ganz anderen
thema die sorge vor energie engpässen im
herbst und winter die überschattet ja
gerade die korona frage wo stehen wir
eigentlich wie infektiös deutschland
gerade wirklich ist das lässt sich nicht
so einfach bestimmen was auch daran
liegt dass sich viele gar nicht mehr
testen zumindest nicht offiziell und
darum ist die aussagekraft offizieller
instanzen nicht unbedingt belastbar
andere länder wie die schweiz die
niederlande belgien oder österreich
helfen sich schon länger mit abwasser
daten auf diese weise erkennt man zum
beispiel ob sich neue virusvarianten
verbreiten bzw eine neue welle im
anmarsch ist in deutschland ist man da
noch in der pilotphase über die in
stuttgart berichtet eva schiller
stuttgart setzt schon länger auf die
aussagekraft der ausscheidungen im
abwasser sechs mal pro tag nehmen
mitarbeiter der kläranlage eine probe im
labor bestimmen sie dann mit pcr tests
die tägliche corona virenlast
amtlichen statistik ein riesenvorteil
unser abwasser in stuttgart ist maximal
vier stunden unterwegs bis es hier im
klärwerk ankommt und daneben wir denn
die probe und können messen und diesen
zeitvorteil den kommt man tatsächlich
nutzen es ist vor allem dem feuer von
laborleiter peter schilling
zuzuschreiben dass aus persönlichem
feldversuch frühwarnsystem wurde denn
seine daten zeigen jede corona welle war
gut eine woche vorher im abwasser
ablesbar und so versorgt jetzt wo sich
immer weniger menschen testen lassen die
kläranlage das gesundheitsamt mit
tagesaktuellen corona werten
das abwasser monitoren ist das der erste
werte ansteigt ein frühwarnsystem würden
dann ganz schnell alle akteure
informieren dann weitere maßnahmen
leiden sich dann aber um aus den anderen
parametern auf also wie viele
krankenhausbetten sind belegt und
weitere stuttgart und andere städte seit
märz teil einer bundesweiten
pilotstudie ergebnisse sollen aber erst
2023 vorliegen während viele andere
länder wie die schweiz österreich
großbritannien längst auf die abwasser
überwachung bauen in der schweiz decken
proben aus 100 kläranlagen mittlerweile
70 prozent der bevölkerung ab es geht
nicht nur um die infektions lage sondern
auch um neue varianten dort konnten wir
zeigen dass wir bis zu zwei wochen
früher in der lage waren diese varianten
im abwasser zu finden ganz klar es ist
eine sehr gute kosteneffiziente
möglichkeit informationen über die
pandemie zu bekommen es gibt glaube ich
wenig was dagegen spricht deutschland
verpasst eine chance vor allem im
hinblick auf den herbst findet virologe
martin stürmer bei uns ist es halt die
praktische umsetzung an der es im
augenblick aber insofern muss man schon
sagen dass wir da vielleicht wieder zu
genau hinschauen wollten wieder zu viel
selber ausprobieren wollten anstatt die
erfahrungen um uns herum zu nutzen und
möglicherweise hier etwas schneller auf
diese methode drauf zu springen wir
fragen den gesundheitsminister warum das
so lange dauert das abwasser monitoren
kommt spät wir beginnen es jetzt ist es
schon am platz in mehr als 20 städten
aber damit kann man keine
flächendeckende überwachung des virus
geschehens durchführen daher denen wir
es jetzt aus laborleiter peter schilling
würde sich wünschen dass jetzt schnell
und unbürokratisch jede kläranlage mit
eigenem labor ihre stadt mit abwasser
daten versorgt denn das stuttgarter
beispiel zeigt es kann so einfach sein
wenn einer die initiative ergreift
so wir machen jetzt weiter mit einem
überblick über sportliche erfolge gundel
es gab ja heute sehr viel mehr als die
fußball-wm der frauen
in der ersten runde des dfb pokals haben
die bundesligisten mit ausnahme von
hertha bsc den erwartungen entsprochen
und ihre spiele problemlos gewonnen
sowie schalke 04 hoffenheim der sc
freiburg und mönchengladbach mit neun
toren auswärts auch augsburg hat sich
für die zweite hauptrunde qualifiziert
sowie mainz 05 ausgeschieden ist dagegen
die hertha aus berlin im
elfmeterschießen gegen eintracht
braunschweig
als erster profi vom rb leipzig ist
christoph koch zu deutschlands fußballer
des jahres gekürt worden der
französische torjäger setzte sich bei
der vom kicker organisierten
journalisten wahl knapp gegen den ex
bayern lewandowski durch trainer des
jahres ist christian streich seit über
zehn jahren chefcoach des sc freiburg
und zur fußballerin des jahres wurde
nationalspielerin
leer schüler gewählt die frischgebackene
vize europameisterin vom fc bayern
münchen
formel 1 weltmeister max verstappen hat
den großen preis von ungarn gewonnen von
startplatz zehn hat sich der
niederländer in seinem red bull nach
vorne gearbeitet es ist sein achter sieg
im 13 saison rennen auf platz zwei und
drei für das britische mercedes duo
lewis hamilton und george russell
sebastian vettel landete auf platz zehn
mit schumacher auf 14 und noch ein
niederländischer triumph annemieke van
vleuten hat die erste tour de france der
frauen gewonnen bei der spektakulären
bergankunft auf der place de delphi kam
die 39 jahre alte zeit war
olympiasiegerin als erste über die
ziellinie und verteidigte das gelbe
trikot das sie gestern übernommen hatte
ihre landsfrau die volle ring wurde auf
der schlussetappe und im
gesamtklassement zweite johannes lippert
beendete die tour als beste deutsche auf
platz 14
sportlich steht nächste woche auch noch
einiges an aber nicht nur wie jeden
sonntag von uns für sie der ausblick auf
die kommende woche
[Musik]
in österreich endet am ersten august die
korona quarantäne pflicht wer infiziert
ist sich aber nicht krank fühlt soll das
haus verlassen und arbeiten dürfen so
das gesundheitsministerium
allerdings mit einschränkungen unter
anderem gelte in innenräumen masken
pflicht und für krankenhäuser oder
pflegeheime ein betretungsverbot
ebenfalls am montag wird das urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs zu den
deutschen seenotrettung schiffen swatch
3 und 4 erwartet es geht um die frage ob
die italienischen behörden die schiffe
2020 im sizilianischen hafen fest setzen
durften weil die schiffe migranten
aufnehmen wird swatch italien eine
politische motivation vor
russlands präsident putin wird am
freitag erneut den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan empfangen in sotschi
am schwarzen meer auf der tagesordnung
dürfte neben syrien auch die ukraine
stehen die türkei war in dem konflikt
zuletzt als vermittler aufgetreten und
hatte sich für die wiederaufnahme der
ukrainischen getreideexporte eingesetzt
und am freitag startet die fußball
bundesliga in die neue saison mit dem
spiel eintracht frankfurt amtierende
europa die gewinner gegen rekordmeister
fc bayern münchen
der ausblick von simone friedrich das
wetter in dieser ersten augustwoche
bleibt überwiegend trocken und heiß
morgen kann es nur im osten und in der
mitte bei vielen wolken schauer und
gewitter geben sonst mehr sonne am
nachmittag aber auch im süden einzelne
gewitter bei 18 bis 31 grad am dienstag
meist freundlich 22 bis 32 grad mittwoch
sonnig und sehr heiß bis 37 grad große
hitze auch am donnerstag im nordwesten
gewitter
dann war's das an dieser stelle heute
von uns um 0.30 melden sich die kollegen
von der heute redaktion und wir uns
morgen wieder zur gewohnten zeit und
einen schönen abend
[Musik]